FELIPE HOFFA: Let's talk
about data-- big data.
Have you ever run
an SQL query that
has taken 10 minutes to run?
An hour?
10 days?
How much time have you spent
determining the right indexes
and building them?
How much space will they
take up in your database?
Or maybe you've already
discovered the power
of [INAUDIBLE].
Are you impressed
by how [INAUDIBLE]
can solve the same
problems in an hour or two?
If so, how did you choose what
kind of network, amount of RAM,
and CPU cores were involved?
Perhaps you've
dreamed about taking
all your Google Analytics
data and joining it
with all the data in
your CRM database.
But how long would that take?
What if I told
you that you could
run all these queries
in seconds, not hours,
without worrying about
any of these problems?
No indexes, no virtual machines,
just your data, Google,
and you.
I'm Felipe Hoffa from the
Google Developer Relations team.
And today, we're going to
talk about Google BigQuery.
BigQuery is a cloud
database run by Google.
It's capable of analyzing
terabytes of data in seconds.
And to start, you
only need to know SQL.
If you know how to
write SQL queries,
you already know
how to query it.
In fact, there are plenty
of interesting public data
sets shared in BigQuery,
ready to be queried by you.
You'll get a free
monthly [INAUDIBLE]
to do so, so why
not start right now?
If you are ready
to get started, it
doesn't get any
simpler than this.
With most other
databases, you first
need to answer many
implementation questions
before getting to the
two essential ones.
What's my data?
And what questions do
I want to ask from it?
With BigQuery, basic
pricing depends only
on those two questions.
BigQuery will charge
you for data storage
and for the amount of
data each query possesses.
That's it.
So BigQuery is a database
in the Cloud by Google,
SQL compatible, and focuses the
essentials of data analysis.
And most importantly,
it analyzes data really,
really fast.
This is an SQL query.
It's simple, but
it's doing a lot.
It's running a
regular expression.
It's aggregating data.
It's sorting the results.
And this particular
one will be processing
230 gigabytes of data
over a billion rows.
Don't try this at home.
Your database might
not like that.
But in BigQuery, it will only
take-- it's already done.
Now, it's your turn
to give it a try.
If you already have lots of
data to analyze and understand,
you'll love being
able to analyze it
faster than ever before.
Individuals and companies
around the world
are using BigQuery to understand
their [INAUDIBLE] behavior
or to [INAUDIBLE]
their logs [INAUDIBLE]
and improve the performance
of their systems,
or to maximize their profit,
finding relationships
previously invisible.
You can also use
BigQuery to analyze
any of the very large public
data sets already available
in it.
You may be about to
discover that BigQuery
is one of the best
places to share data
and let other people
instantly analyze it.
And of course, you
always have full control
over who can access your data.
We publish plenty of
videos and case studies
highlighting these stories.
Check them out.
Getting started is simple, as
BigQuery has an easy-to-use web
UI.
You can also connect it to your
favorite programming framework
and analysis tools
thanks to its REST API.
There's a big
ecosystem of products
that [INAUDIBLE] BigQuery
to store and analyze
their big data.
You can easily connect it
to other Google products,
like [INAUDIBLE]
and Apps Script,
or access data from Google
Analytics [INAUDIBLE],
to name a few.
The open source community has
also embraced BigQuery with
connectors to [INAUDIBLE] for
powerful analysis or the log
collector [INAUDIBLE], to send
all your logs to be queried
to analyse.
Also check our growing list
of partners on our third party
tools space.
So what do you want to do next?
Do you want to know how
BigQuery works internally
or how to query one of
the many public data sets?
Or are you ready to
upload your own data
and start learning from it?
Whatever you want to
do, we are here to help.
Check out the videos
and documentations
we prepared for you.
Or for a collection of the
interesting articles I found
about BigQuery, check out
reddit.com/r/bigquery.
Or to read and share
interesting queries
[INAUDIBLE] public
data, go to bigqueri.es.
If you are having
trouble while developing,
join us at stackoverflow.com.
And if you need
enterprise-level support,
we also offer various support
packages to meet your needs.
Whatever you do, stay curious.
And why not share this
video with your friends?
From the Google studios
in Mountain View,
I'm Felipe Hoffa.